you got your start on 902 and oh that's
right in one episode the show is now
coming back you know that they recycle
things so much I mean Charlie's Angels
recycles and so it's rare to find
something that is fresh and new but I
think that people really obviously have
there's an audience for that so I think
it's wonderful I always and it's a new
Charlie's Angels coming out as well and
I I just I feel like you know things
that are original are always sort of pop
a little bit but I think people have a
there's a comfort level and in trying to
like relive something and also to to
redo something in the modern time and
I'm always curious how that works out
I'm happy for them because it was a
great cast then and I work with both
Luke Perry and was you know rest in
peace and and Jason Priestley so it was
a thrill back then especially since they
were just heart drops
you know people played such great
characters and since revivals and
reboots are the day and age right now is
there a character you'd ever like to
reboot because I'm sure you get asked
about a smash reboot all the time oh my
god I would quite like to play that
character again it was fun I've never
made so many chorus girls cry I used to
sit in these seasonally all these
amazing young people would do something
incredible and then as scripted I don't
have to go that was terrible and then be
awful to them and I did quite enjoy that
I don't know that says about me it was
it was really fun to be that dreadful
yeah it was quite liberating so I'd do
that ya know here when I came in you see
the only one or have there been others
if you kick me to the curb I'll have no
reason not to come out are you
threatening me
I'm sort of going into the idea that
there's three different decades the 60s
the 80s and the current time and that
women are in relationships they're
married and how that manifests into
something that kind of gain speed and
goes out of control when they find out
that their husbands have been unfaithful
penny for your thoughts I swear when
you'll die
[Music]